So today, I'll be talking about advances in the management of ALL.
I'm going to focus on pH-negative B-cell ALL.
So the question is, how can we improve outcomes in patients with ALL?
In pediatric ALL, our five-year overall survival rates have been 90% or more.
Unfortunately, in adults, this has been in the range of 20% to 80%, and this has depended
on age, biology, as well as comorbidities of patients.
And so novel approaches are clearly needed.
So in terms of the treatment of young adults with ALL, one thing that has changed, many
years ago, when I had just started at the clinic, this retrospective data came out and
was published by both Wendy Stock and Nicholas Wazell.
Showing that in young adults treated with pediatric regimens, these were retrospective
studies, their outcome was much better when they were treated on pediatric cooperative
group trials versus adult cooperative group trials.
And there was a lot of controversy at that time about whether these patients should be
treated by pediatricians.
So this led to C10403.
This was an adult cooperative group trial.
using a pediatric-based regimen.
And based on this trial, I showed that we really could reach similar outcomes by using
a pediatric-based regimen in these young adults with ALL.
But older adults have still remained a problem.
And so this is data from Wendy Stock showing the outcomes of patients enrolled on the CA-LGB
cooperative group trials.
And you can see that in these older patients that are 60 years of age and older, their
outcome has really been quite poor.
And this is probably for a number of reasons.
Poor tolerance of chemotherapy and comorbidities.
And also the biology.
The biology of the disease.
And so the question is, what can we do to help improve this?
And this has really been a focus of many of the current clinical trials.
And so the question has been, can we incorporate novel agents?
Can we decrease the amount of traditional chemotherapy we give?
And also, can we incorporate CAR-T therapy in the upfront setting?
And so two of the agents that have been novel.
They have been FDA-approved.
Inotuzumab has been FDA-approved for relapsed refractory B-cell ALL based on the INOVATE
trial, showing that it was superior to standard of care chemotherapy.
Blinitumumab, which is the anti-CD19 bispecific T-cell engaging antibody, has been FDA-approved
in both MRD-positive BALL and the T-cell engaging antibody.
As well as relapsed refractory B-cell ALL.
And so these agents now have been incorporated up front.
And so probably one of the largest recent studies that has really changed our standard
of care in the upfront treatment of patients with newly diagnosed B-cell ALL has been the
E1910 trial.
This was led by Mark Litzel.
This trial looked at chemotherapy versus chemotherapy.
Plus, Blinitumumab as post-remission treatment.
And for the purposes of this specific trial, looked at Blinitumumab in post-remission treatment
in those patients that were MRD-negative.
And so this was presented at ASH and really is kind of astounding in that it showed an
overall survival in those patients treated with Blinitumumab in frontline therapy and
really has led to improvement.
And so in this trial, we were able to do a standard of care change.
Now, notably in those patients that are 55 years of age and older, there was not, again,
this trial was not powered to look at that older age group, but there was not as much
benefit in those patients.
And so there still has been a question for those patients that are 55 or 60 years of
age or older, what do we do to improve outcome?
And so this is an older study.
And so this is a study that was done in a study that was done in the U.S.
in the United States.
It was done in the United States.
And it was done in the United States.